uh welcome back uh to best car fixes
this is muhammad haroni there is please
subscribe share and like today we have a
different car let us try to see how we
can program proximity in honda odyssey
2014 and up the car push button this is
no more um
[Music]
electrical electrical key where you put
the key in the ignition here and also it
only have
uh something called emergency key where
you can open
can you open it for me this one
give me some help
okay this is the emergency key take it
out for me
okay
there is no chip on it this one original
you can get after market also but this
one is original and there is no chip on
it
okay
so now i'm gonna use i'm not gonna use
hundred tools because honda asks you
sometime
to do popular
pin code out code and inquire this is
original for this part number
as you see the assembly
uh can you open it for me
we're gonna open it
this is original remote
okay
some of them the battery come out you
have to open it and put the battery and
some of them they have more than one
buttons like this one you have lock
unlock
trunk
and left right sliding door and panic
some of them they have remote starter
too so okay i'm gonna leave this one
here you can put this one inside
in case
let's see
and also some of them they have removed
one and remove two if it have a memory
seat
so i'm going to leave this one here
we're going to come
and try to program this car
uh can i close the door right
i'm going to put the hazard on
just
not to leave the bcm and i go to imo
accept
and then go to honda
from the honda let it go
and check
we're gonna check
manual selection
because sometimes you cannot get it with
dramatic honda
honda have a lot of cars
get the letter o as in oh um
onion
odyssey
smart key
push to start push and third this is
push to start
because before pushing to start there is
a different one i'm gonna say okay
now we're gonna go into
i'm gonna go through um scar
you say is the ignition turn by pressing
the star light
i will say no
now press and hold so you come here
press and hold till the ignition light
ignition will come on i'm gonna press
and hold don't leave it
yes here ignition come on
i'm gonna turn the ac off
ready also
i don't need no copyright
now
everything is okay
ignition is awesome please release it i
release it
now we're gonna go into
uh how to communicate and configure the
system
this is the same way that it go to all
hondas
if you are doing honda acura
i believe this is the same way that you
can go with it be sure that the battery
is good here you see it light up if it's
not some of them they come without the
battery
you see now it look at the immo
scan
and then i will go to it here will
become
yellow or orange
here we have 8080 person
i will say all kilos
it have one two three four five okay
let's go
start don't tell me need uh
there is no dtc
here
here must be all keyless remote
register one key remote have to be in
the car yes we have this one here
let's say okay
please turn the ignition off do not
press anything i'm gonna turn the
ignition off
i turn it off
please wait for seven second eight six
it keeps a weight okay we're gonna wait
please take one original key
into the vehicle
i will say okay here's the key
is the ignition turned
by normal say no
let me see
nothing i will say no
now i'm gonna hold again
one two three four five six
seven
eight
nine twelve
yes
you see ignition is okay release it
i release my feet my hand
i will say okay
one is okay
whether the new model generally refer to
model 2020 whether the new model
generally refer to model after 2020 i
will say no
so it's not 220. if after 2020 maybe it
will not do it
so now we check the vehicle
keep programming succeed would you like
to learn another is already take the key
and already program it do you want to
learn another ski i say no
success
turn the ignition switch off do not
press the foot better
i turn the key off
please wait for eight seconds
we have like six seconds till now
we have like seven seconds
since we started
please turn the ignition on do not press
the brake button don't push the brake
for the just turn the ignition on so we
gotta be one
two
yes ignition is on
you see everything is okay
all kilos guided
are both keyless access and immobilizer
indicator turn off
yes
say yes
success
you're gonna read the par number please
turn the ignition off
the ignition is off
i don't know what part number he need
through he say step six read key number
okay he want to tell us what number is
here it's gonna be only one
please turn the ignition on do not press
the foot because if you press the foot
the car will start to time the key is on
registration is complete please turn the
ignition off
i turn the ignition off
check all key access remote to ensure
each will start the engine so first i'm
going to push the brake
and start the car
my car start perfect
now i'm gonna see if this door lock
this key number is one
so i'm gonna
escape everything
we are good to go now i'm gonna turn
this off
when the car is running maybe door lock
unlock would not work
open the door
close it
lock
unlock
okay i'm gonna try the the trunk
and i'm gonna push on hold
on yes i see it's going up
good
push again to go down
supposed to go down
okay
it doesn't go down so let me see the
passenger side
beautiful
push it
i don't know why the trunk doesn't want
to come back
now the door here
watch
it's close
now here
i don't know why this doesn't want to
walk but let me see
hold
i see it
okay
beautiful
thank you for watching best car fixes
please
subscribe share and like i'll see you in
another video this is muhammad haroon
idris